Щоб щасливим бути, що треба?
Щоб поруч були тато і мама.
Ну, особливо я пам’ятаю, як стріляли. Моя мама… вона померла.
Я хочу всім дітям побажати, щоб у них були гарні батьки, був дім.
Щоб у нашій країні не було війни.
Для цих дітей щастя - це коли є дім і батьки поруч.
У минулому житті у них це було.
Але під час повномасштабної війни вони все втратили.
І тепер вчаться жити по-новому.
Семирічна Каріна нещодавно почала грати на фортепіано.
Заняття музикою - частина її психологічної реабілітації.
У березні 2022 року дівчинка пережила смерть мами і тата.
Їхню машину російські окупанти обстріляли під час втечі з Чернігівщини.
Тікаючи від куль, машина наїхала на міну.
Дивом у тій автівці вижила лише Каріна та її двоюрідний брат.
Перед блок-постом вони звернули вбік і потрапили на протитанкову міну.
Авто підірвалося, тато Каріни загинув на місці.
Про сестру я не знаю, що і як, і чи можна було щось зробити.
А Каріна з братиком вилетіли через панорамне вікно.
Друзі родини, які їхали у машині позаду, забрали дітей з місця трагедії і повезли до лікарні у Чернігів.
Там ще кілька днів дівчинка не знала, що стала сиротою.
Каріну передали під опіку рідній тітці та дядькові, яких дівчинка тепер називає мамою і татом.
Я захотіла до Руслани поїхати.
Так мене бабуся і дідусь Саша привезли в Київ до мами.
Я зараз живу у Києві. Мені в Києві подобається.
Щоб щасливим бути, що треба?
Щоб поруч були тато і мама.
Каріна регулярно займається із психологом, має нових друзів у школі.
Та все одно часто згадує своє колишнє життя.
Це в Чернігові. Це зима, ми гуляли в садочку, де я вчилася.
Я пам’ятаю, що там були бабуся, тато і мама.
Сумую за друзями, за вчителями…
Я сказала їй, що тепер мама і тато на небі, а вона: "А чи можуть вони повернутися?".
Потім три години щось своє робить, а потім руку підніме і каже: "А вони це бачать? А це бачать?.."
Сьогодні в Україні понад 60 тисяч дітей позбавлені батьківської опіки.
Більше 9-ти тисяч з них набули цього статусу під час повномасштабної війни.
А півтори тисячі дітей стали сиротами через те, що їхні батьки загинули через дії російських окупантів.
У Національній соціальній сервісній службі України пояснюють:
зараз найчастіше сиріт передають під опіку родичам - тіткам, дядькам, бабусям чи дідусям -
оскільки це шанс на реабілітацію в колі родини.
Утім, є випадки, коли у дитини не лишається нікого.
Така доля спіткала семирічного Іллю з Маріуполя.
Нервова система його захистила і відрізала йому пам'ять. Він нічого не казав. Він просто не пам’ятав і все…
За свідченнями маріупольців, батьків Іллі росіяни вбили у березні 22-го в рідному місті, коли ті вийшли на пошуки харчів.
Обоє не повернулися додому, де їх кілька діб чекав син.
Хлопчика прихистили небайдужі.
У цей час подружжя Марії та Володимира жили у Слов'янську і хотіли всиновити дитину, яка потребує батьків.
Нам телефонують і кажуть, що жінка, в якої він сидів місяць у Дніпрі, лягає в лікарню, і треба на ранок його забрати.
Заходиш в дім, де сидить Ілля в кімнаті,
і тебе зустрічає життєрадісний хлопчик, показує свої малюнки.
Він сказав: "Знаєте, мама і тато в мене померли. Я такий маленький, як я буду сам в цьому світі".
Він сам все сказав. І я кажу:
"Якщо ти хочеш, я Маша, а це Вова - ми можемо стати твоїми батьками.
Батьки будуть дивитися на тебе з неба, а ми будемо тут на землі. Ти цього хочеш?". "Так, хочу"…
Я хочу всім дітям побажати, щоб у них були гарні батьки, був дім.
Щоб в нашій країні не було війни.
Уже рік як родина евакуювалася зі Слов'янська і живе у Києві разом з Іллею.
Але всиновити його пара поки не може.
Знаєте, війна… А система - вона була складна, всі про це знають, але вона не стала легше, вона стала ще важче.
Юридично Марія і Володимир змогли оформити лише опіку.
Через те, що батьки Іллі зникли у нині окупованому Маріуполі,
підтвердити їхню смерть офіційно поки неможливо.
В опіки є багато привілеїв. Ми можемо виїжджати за кордон.
Ось мій чоловік - він виїзний.
Тому, опіка так зацікавила багатьох людей.
Утім, черг охочих взяти сиріт під опіку або всиновити немає,
кажуть у Київському центрі соціально-психологічної реабілітації дітей.
Діти, яких не вдалося передати під опіку родичам, потрапляють сюди.
Директор відверто каже: хотів би, аби вихованців було якомога менше.
Однак через війну заклад нині переповнений.
Ну, напевне ж, невипадково, центр наш розрахований на 100 дітей, по минулих роках скільки в нас було дітей?
Ну, 50-60. Зараз 130! No comments!
У такому центрі дитині не може бути добре. Бо це ненормально! Дитині має бути добре в сім'ї!
Нині у закладі живуть і проходять реабілітацію діти від трьох до вісімнадцяти років.
Тут вони мають сеанси арт-терапії, спорт, ігри і спілкування з психологом.
От коли ти чуєш слово "підтримка", з яким це кольором тобі асоціюється?
Зелений!
- Зелений хочеш, так?
Обличчя десятирічної Поліни служба у справах дітей просить не показувати.
Кілька тижнів тому дівчинка стала сиротою і потрапила у запорізький дитбудинок.
Але через обстріли РФ була змушена покинути рідне місто з іншими вихованцями - усіх евакуювали у столицю.
Особливо я пам’ятаю, як стріляли.
Моя мама пила, в неї був рак печінки. І вона померла.
Коли вона потрапила до нас в заклад, то вона свого "помагайчика" намалювала,
він ось такий - заховався, в нього страх.
Тобто у неї померла мама, немає тата, в цьому світі вона відчуває себе самотньою.
З однією дівчинкою малювали неіснуючу тварину, вона намалювала дракона, щоб перемогти Путіна.
Психологиня, яка працює дітьми у закладі, показує малюнки Поліни та інших підопічних.
Каже, з усіма пропрацьовують травму війни, втрати і почуття провини.
Більшість дітей мріють про нову родину.
З першої зустрічі дітки кажуть "Забирайте нас, будь ласка! Ми вже хочемо до вас".
"Хочу в родину, щоб мене любили".
Впоратися з новими викликами працівникам дитячих закладів стає дедалі важче.
Просто катастрофічно не вистачає вихователів!
Ми б, може, і більше дітей прийняли, але, на жаль, умови роботи і оплата праці, ну, скажімо так…
Аби розвантажити заклади і заохотити українців активніше забирати дітей в родини,
уряд зменшив перелік документів для оформлення опіки та дозволив ставати опікунами хрещеним батькам.
Для усиновлення відтепер є можливість подати заявку у сервісі "Дія" - онлайн.
Однак охочих більше не стало.
У нас за час війни було всиновлено близько 700 дітей.
Тобто динаміка порівняно з 2021 роком впала в два рази.
Це зумовлено тим, що під час війни у нас зупинено усиновлення іноземцями.
Є багато дітей, які з інвалідністю, і, на жаль, дуже мало усиновлюють дітей з інвалідністю,
а таких дітей все-таки дуже велика питома частка у загальній кількості дітей для усиновлення.
Ми хочемо, щоб на перше місце ставилися інтереси дитини,
і коли вона усиновлюється, щоб ми точно були впевнені, що її назад не повернуть.
Для перевірки мотивації потенційних опікунів або усиновлювачів
у співпраці з волонтерами створили спеціальний чат-бот "Дитина не сама".
У ньому кандидати базово знайомляться з процедурою та збором документів,
після чого проходять тримісячне навчання, де психологи визначають,
чи готові люди взяти дитину-сироту до себе.
У чат-бот за рік його існування звернулося понад 24 тисячі українців.
Хтось вирішив "Я візьму дитину в свою сім'ю і зможу виїхати за кордон зі своїм чоловіком".
Хтось вирішив: "Я візьму дитину, значить, можу не служити в Збройних Силах України".
Різна є мотивація!
Тому, нам було важливо пояснити, що значить - взяти дитину, які вимоги, хто може, хто не може.
Кофтинка!
Давай я буду складати!
Ось так от береш, ось так, завертаєш.
Тимур та Інна Мірошніченки складають речі для хлопчика із Житомирської області,
якого вже півроку намагаються всиновити.
Малюк має вади здоров’я від народження, але це не зупинило подружжя, в яких уже є двоє власних дітей.
Ця дитина вже народжена, вже десь є і так само, як і ми, страждає від повномасштабної війни. Куди далі тягнути?
Увесь шлях - від чат-бота і навчань із психологом до збору документів -  подружжя вже пройшло.
Залишилося лише рішення суду про всиновлення.
Подружжя стикалося з історіями родин, які хотіли б всиновити виключно здорову дитину.
Нам розповідали історії різні, що новонароджена дитина, яка не обтяжена анамнезом,
батьками-алкоголіками, коштує 50 тисяч доларів.
І черга з охочих стоїть ще задовго до народження дитини.
Тобто в службах "промацують" людей на можливість платити за дитину,
і потім між собою вони встановлюють конект,
і далі люди чекають, коли така дитина з'явиться, їм телефонують і вони дитину забирають.
Можуть приховувати певні анкети дітей,
хоча всі анкети дітей розміщені на сайті Мінсоцполітики.
Скарги є до нас, ми оперативно на це реагуємо.
Мінімізувати зловживання в регіонах у Національній соціальній сервісній службі
пропонують шляхом автоматизації системи підбору усиновлювачів для конкретної дитини,
тобто виключити з процедури людський фактор.
Ми теж розглядаємо питання внесення змін у процесуальні кодекси
для закріплення чітких строків розгляду судами різних інстанцій
справ стосовно усиновлення і присвоєння статусу дітей.
І також хочемо активізувати процес можливості усиновлення дітей,
які зараз вивезені за кордон на безпечні території,
щоб з ними так само могли знайомитися онлайн.
Війна так чи інакше і далі негативно впливатиме на життя дітей,
позбавлених батьківського піклування, вважає Луцик.
Це і неможливість повноцінно передати дитину в нову родину,
якщо рідні батьки загинули на окупованих територіях.
Це і вимушена евакуація, зруйновані дитячі будинки та інтернати,
а також депортація росіянами деяких вихованців в окупований Крим,
як це сталося з Миколаївським будинком дитини.
А травмованим дітям, таким як семирічна Каріна,
доведеться місяцями, якщо не роками проходити психологічну реабілітацію.
Коли людина приймає ситуацію, вона може про неї говорити.
Це називається прийняття. У Каріни немає прийняття.
Вона вірить у щось краще.
Вона декілька днів тому підходить і каже: "А вони можуть колись до нас повернутися?"
Заспокоєння дівчинка продовжує знаходити у музиці.